[Musique]
le 9 septembre 2022 le président de la
République annonçait le lancement d'une
concertation nationale pour construire
un pacte et une loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricoles sur notre île ce
processus de concertation copiloté par
le Département la préfecture et la
Chambre d'Agriculture s'est traduit par
l'organisation le 28 mars dernier d'une
journée de travail sous forme d'atelier
en présence des représentants du monde
agricole professionnel structures
d'enseignement agricoles ou encore
syndicat ce mardi 25 avril tous se sont
retrouvés dans l'hémicycle du Palais de
la source pour assurer la restitution de
ces travaux c'est important qui est une
mobilisation des acteurs locaux puisque
il nous faut faire entendre une fois de
plus la voix de la Réunion par rapport à
l'Hexagone ce matin ces trois ateliers
qui sont en restitution qui
investissaient tenu à Saint Joseph au
mois de mars dernier et notamment des
sujets extrêmement important comme la
transmission
des exploitations comme la problématique
foncière comme les outils de maîtrise de
ce foncier mais aussi par les de la
formation de nos agriculteurs les
déboucher pour ce ces jeunes qui sont
inscrits dans les lycées agricoles donc
beaucoup de sujets que certaines qui
méritent sans doute qui est des
ajustements législatifs d'autres qui
sont purement techniques d'autres
purement financiers mais en tout cas on
a essayé de balayer avec l'ensemble des
acteurs ce travail qui nous a été
demandé par le gouvernement pour la
Réunion mais aussi pour la France
hexagonale la contribution de la Réunion
dans cette grande concertation pour
l'avenir du monde agricole sera envoyé à
Paris d'ici le 15 mai prochain pour
alimenter les réflexions au National
[Musique]